Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Da dove veniamo? Chi siamo? Dove andiamo?
È Gaugin.
Woody Allen chiudeva anche con,
"Dove ceniamo questa sera?"
Abbiamo visto, agli inizi,
Margherita Hack.
Certamente dobbiamo chiederci -
questi grandi astrofisici,
questo è Nanni Bignami -
come risolvono la situazione?
Iniziano col Big Bang.
Poi il grande botto,
le molecole, i pianeti.
In sala qui, sicuramente,
c'è qualcuno che si chiama Luca:
Last Universal Common Ancestor.
Poi arriviamo -
lo potete presentare così -
(Risate)
Poi arriviamo naturalmente a noi.
Siamo qui, al Teatro Parenti,
Milano, Europa, pianeta terra.
Siamo un puntolino in mezzo
a questa meravigliosa galassia,
la Via Lattea,
e stiamo aspettando di scontrarci
con un'altra galassia: Andromeda.
Però tranquilli: quando accadrà,
avremo già lasciato il pianeta.
Noi ce ne saremo già andati.
Però bisogna cercare di capire
un po' le cose del mondo.
In fondo, queste serate
sono state bellissime proprio per questo.
Dobbiamo rivolgerci alla logica,
non ci sono altre vie:
al padre della logica, Wittgenstein.
Questo diceva
"Si usa il microscopio, micro;
o si usa il telescopio, macro"
Quindi casca proprio a fagiolo con i temi.
Però qui nasce già un problemino,
perché noi non usiamo
né il microscopio né il telescopio:
usiamo questo aggeggio.
Quindi usiamo il telefono,
lo smartphone, il tablet.
Questo è un problema,
perché non ci relazioniamo
più con le cose,
come diceva Hannah Arendt,
ma con le informazioni.
Questo è un problema.
Quindi finiamo per vivere nell'infosfera,
come dice Luciano Floridi,
avrete letto il suo libro bellissimo.
Quindi è un continuo
creare informazioni, no?
Tutti che parlano, e nessuno che ascolta.
Non so voi, ma io
tutte le mattine, in bicicletta -
avete sentito le vocali aperte,
avrete capito che sono
lombardo, di Pavia -
al mattino giro con la bicicletta
e devo fare degli slalom.
Perché ho una marea, letteralmente,
di sonnambuli, sonnambuli diurni,
che mi vengono incontro.
Sono questi.
È una marea.
Umberto Eco faceva apposta a spingerli:
io non lo posso fare,
ricevo solo degli insulti.
Perché da noi non c'è ancora
questo sistema, come in altri paesi,
dove questi info-maniaci -
sono degli info-maniaci, dei pollicini,
vanno avanti con 240 battute,
adesso quante sono, 480?
Prima di sera hanno scritto
l'equivalente de "La Recherche":
3412.
(Applausi)
Doveva essere "I promessi sposi",
ho detto La Recherche, 3412 pagine:
degli info-maniaci.
Ma cosa vorranno dire?
Anassagora diceva che siamo intelligenti
perché usiamo le mani.
Sì, però qui c'è un problema.
Siamo diventati "Telefono Sapiens",
non Homo Sapiens.
C'è un disastro di -
Dobbiamo cercare di riflettere,
perché questi creano degli "infomi",
e tutto quello che finisce in -oma
va affrontato con cautela.
Addormentano la ragione, in poche parole.
Ci si trova in situazioni di questo tipo:
"Il sonno della ragione"
Quindi dobbiamo andare
dai grandi pensatori,
perché ci aiutino a uscirne.
Non ci può essere che lui:
"Sein und Zeit", essere e tempo.
Mi fermo qui.
Si conforma il contorno di fatto,
lo avrete capito:
l'essere non è più relazionato, relazione.
L'essere nel mondo, "Sein".
"In-der-Welt-Sein"
Non è più questo, ma è
"Sein und Information"
Cioè: siamo informazioni.
Allora qui il problema è -
che si delinea il contorno
del problema, che è questo:
le bugie, le verità alternative.
Provate a pensare alla verità alternativa.
Uno dice: "Cos'hai fumato?
Devo preoccuparmi della tua salute?"
Le fake news.
È un problema.
Ecco, qui è dove viviamo.
Quindi ora dobbiamo cercare di capire
come uscire da queste bugie.
Guardate che ci sono sempre state,
le verità alternative.
Questa è la prima che ci hanno raccontato.
Poi, naturalmente, le conseguenze
sono sotto gli occhi di tutti,
cioè ci credi e ti ritrovi -
ma il problema è che ci sono,
e ci sono sempre state.
Quando cercavamo di documentare
il viaggio di Buffalo Bill
abbiamo trovato sul Corriere
le pubblicità dell'epoca,
"l'elisir di lunga vita",
"perché soffrite?", "pronto a tutto".
Il problema è che oggi ci sono
i generatori di supercazzole,
cioè generatori casuali di supercazzole.
Siamo in una situazione pericolosa.
Dobbiamo riferirci a come uscirne,
imparare dalla storia,
e dobbiamo tornare a Martino.
Martin Heidegger riabilitato,
tutto a posto, eccetera -
tutti gli anni a Lindau
si incontrano i Nobel,
e lui li va ad ascoltare nel '55.
C'è un grandissimo biologo
che ha vinto il premio Nobel
nel '46 per la chimica.
I biologi vincono sempre i premi Nobel
per la fisiologia o medicina,
quasi tutti.
E tanti per la chimica,
non è una cosa strana.
Il nostro buon Wendell Stanley l'ha vinto
perché ha cristallizzato il genoma
del virus del mosaico del tabacco.
Ora qui non ho - Non ho tempo -
La dico!
Le adorabili aguzzine
che hanno organizzato
mi assegnano 12 minuti,
ma in 12 minuti io dico il nome e cognome.
Ho bisogno -
(Applausi)
Seguitemi perché non riesco a finire,
poi ci sono conseguenze.
Lui sente e si spaventa,
perché sente questo che dice:
"Raga" - no raga:
"Signori, guardate che nelle nostre mani
abbiamo gli strumenti
per sintetizzare il vivente"
La famosa foto indica
il regista superiore che dice:
"Caspita, questa è
l'autodistruzione dell'umanità"
E poi un attacco alla vita.
Quindi questa è la situazione.
Come uscirne?
Dobbiamo riconoscere
quello che viene negato: le 3 C.
Clima,
che non è più un cambiamento
ma è un'emergenza, un'urgenza;
CoVid: mi raccomando,
la CoVid, è femminile.
Lo dice l'Accademia della Crusca,
quindi non continuate a dire
il Covid, ma la Covid.
Accademia della Crusca;
Conflitti.
E sono legati tra loro.
Al 16 di maggio, ci siamo
già mangiati il pianeta.
Le risorse che ci offre
per i nostri stili di vita -
che dobbiamo cambiare,
noi dobbiamo desiderare
un'altra normalità -
sono esaurite.
Questa data era a novembre/dicembre,
sino a qualche anno fa;
poi è venuta verso luglio/agosto;
ora dal 16 maggio viviamo a scrocco.
Avremmo bisogno di 1,7 pianeti.
Ne abbiamo uno,
quindi proprio non va bene.
Abbiamo distrutto i principali ecosistemi:
foresta pluviale e barriere coralline.
Nei pochi minuti che mi hanno assegnato,
ogni 10 minuti, 30 tir di plastica
finiscono nei sistemi di acqua.
Quindi, distruggere il pianeta:
ma cosa volete che succeda?
Se lo chiedete alla mia vicina -
la massaia di Voghera, Arbasino docet -
ve lo dice anche lei
il perché ci siamo beccati la CoVid.
Se distruggi il pianeta
e distruggi gli ecosistemi...
In tempi geologici,
siamo andati a pasticciare
con il bestiame per addomesticarlo:
morbillo e tubercolosi.
Siamo andati coi suini,
per addomesticarli: pertosse.
Poi le anatre: l'influenza.
Qui è semplice, abbiamo distrutto
il distruggibile.
Anche la massaia di Voghera
vi fa la lista.
Partiamo dagli anni '80:
HIV, Marburg, Nipah, H5N1, H1N1, la Covid.
Il discorso è molto semplice:
non è pensabile di continuare
in questi termini.
Ce la andiamo a cercare,
distruggendo gli ecosistemi;
ma dove volete che vada?
Gli animali.
Come è stato ricordato,
il 25% di mammiferi sono pipistrelli:
viene a fecalizzare nel vostro giardino.
E se per di più lo si mangia,
come in alcune culture
e mercati occidentali
dell'Africa e dell'Asia,
è chiaro che andiamo a cercarci
le zoonosi, gli spillover.
Naturalmente, tutto ciò moltiplica
le ingiustizie e le disuguaglianze,
e quindi conflitti.
E questa è la terza C.
Quindi ci troviamo in questa situazione,
e quindi dobbiamo desiderare
un'altra normalità, e dobbiamo cambiare.
Come?
Ce lo dice Hölderlin:
dove c'è il pericolo, c'è la salvezza.
Se queste sono le icone di come viviamo,
non viviamo nell'Antropocene
ma viviamo nel "Plasticene".
Le icone sono queste,
viviamo di carne rossa.
La biomassa degli otto miliardi
di umani, in questo momento,
equivale alla biomassa
del miliardo di bovini
che stiamo allevando intensivamente.
Il clima lo abbiamo distrutto
non tanto per i gas serra
prodotti dai trasporti,
ma dagli intestini di questi bovini,
che emettono più gas serra di -
Quindi c'è un problema chiarissimo:
dobbiamo cambiare.
Migliaia di aeroporti,
migliaia di chilometri di strade:
non va bene.
632 pagine, il rapporto Dasgupta -
so che non lo leggerete, ma scaricatelo
e guardate almeno l'indice.
È indicato già nell'indice, come uscirne.
Si può uscirne.
Vogliamo vedere quelle condizioni?
Non volete rinunciare alla carne rossa?
Voilà, dalle staminali si fa il burger:
agricoltura cellulare,
si può fare di pesci, di crostacei,
di quello che volete.
Si prendono i muscoli -
Pensate che 1 kg di carne rossa
sono 15.000 litri d'acqua;
pensate alla sofferenza degli animali;
pensate che avete disboscato l'equivalente
della superficie del continente africano
per fare allevamenti intensivi.
Non si può continuare in questi termini.
Costa ancora sui 20 €.
Non è un granché, perché manca -
è buono come sapore,
ma manca la componente di grasso,
perché sappiamo fare benissimo
le staminali dei miociti.
Ma le signore pagano
per fare la liposuzione:
dovreste farvi pagare
perché regalate gli adipociti.
Comunque, non ho tempo ora
per queste cose, però -
(Applausi)
Non ho tempo, è già sparito
l'orologino, mette un'ansia -
Danke schön.
Si può trovare la maniera
di fare proteine in altre maniere:
ad esempio, Samantha Gregoretti
sta provando con i batteri
idrogenotrofi, dall'aria!
Questi batteri, con la CO2 che respiriamo,
producono aminoacidi,
quindi lo chef stellare molecolare
potrà fare quello che vuole.
Pensate a tutto il dibattito
su termodistruttori e termoutilizzatori.
La componente dell'umido
è quella che costa di più da smaltire:
ma facciamoci crescere le larve,
è semplicissimo, degli insetti,
le igienizziamo e ce le sbafiamo.
È bello e fatto.
Guardate, è importante
perché ora vi presento
la collezione primavera-estate
delle pandemie: è questa.
Ebola, H5N1, ultimo il vaiolo,
in attesa della sfilata autunno-inverno,
che sarà un po' più consistente.
Quindi è il caso di cambiare,
di desiderare di cambiare.
Dobbiamo farlo
perché poi c'è il conflitto,
perché tutte queste situazioni
accentuano i conflitti:
e questo è il risultato,
quindi non se ne può uscire.
Abbiamo gli strumenti,
abbiamo sentito quelli
che mi hanno preceduto.
Hanno gettato dei germogli
importantissimi.
I conflitti -
Adesso lo dico in maniera provocatoria,
perché abbiamo sentito delle lezioni
con un peso specifico notevolissimo.
Ragazzi: il metaverso.
Centinaia di migliaia di morti,
paesi distrutti;
ma la Storia non insegna niente?
Orazi e Curiazi, mettetevi nel metaverso.
Ci viene detto
che stanno decidendo le strategie
su come attaccare,
contrattaccare, difendersi
con i giochi di guerra al tavolino -
e facciamola fuori lì.
Pensate alla disfida di Barletta.
Mi sembrerebbe un...
Lo so, è provocatorio,
ma qui sembra che nessuno abbia le idee,
e dico anch'io la mia.
Ci potrebbe stare?
Vediamo.
Dobbiamo desiderare
un'altra normalità, è chiaro.
Devo chiudere assolutamente.
Mi piace perché hanno imbrattato
la statua, l'altro giorno,
a Margaret Thatcher.
Su alcune statue andrei anch'io.
Però c'è un limite, a una signora non -
Margaret Thatcher diceva,
quando arrivava il momento,
TINA, There Is No Alternative.
Fine. Stop.
Non c'è altro da fare,
andiamo a casa con questa convinzione.
Vi è stato detto più volte,
desiderare un'altra normalità.
Qui adesso c'è un po' buio,
ma potrei indicarvi:
tu, tu, io, noi,
non siamo dei buoni antenati.
Che pianeta consegniamo ai piccolini?
Non va bene.
Questa è molto bella:
non tornare alla normalità,
perché era quella la normalità.
Siete stanchi, lo so, ho finito,
ma devo finire citando
il mio coreografo preferito, Béjart.
Béjart, in un certo momento,
viene premiato
come il più raffinato coreografo.
Gli danno questo premio incredibile;
e lui, nella prolusione: "Malgré la merde"
Tutti restano sconcertati
per ciò che dice,
poi fa un bel discorso, esprime repulsione
verso l'epoca dove siamo finiti.
Sì, perché siamo qui tutti quanti
belli, privilegiati ecc.
Però onestamente è un'epoca -
Però ragazzi, "je crois" -
quel "je crois" ha una forza incredibile.
È stato detto più volte: non è vero
che la nostra azione non ha influenza.
Non è vero che ci sono gli iper-oggetti,
e qualunque cosa faccia non ha azione.
Ce l'ha eccome.
Ed è necessario
tornare ad essere generosi.
Qui ci si è dimenticati
che cos'è la generosità.
Guardate che si vince
solo con la generosità,
perché a chiuderci prendiamo
la "sucker paoyff", la paga del babbeo,
alla fine, tutti quanti -
Uno dei maestri che abbiamo visto,
Rita Levi-Montalcini.
Non ho tempo di raccontarvi
la mia storia con Rita.
Però: esercizio Montalcini numero cinque.
Ve lo consegno,
non si va a casa senza compiti.
Siccome, come uscite di qui:
ciao, Spritz, movida -
Conosco i miei polli.
All'uscita avete diritto,
avendo sopportato tutto ciò,
di raccogliere uno di questi,
adesso me ne è rimasto in tasca uno.
Qui dentro c'era il bozzolo
del baco da seta.
Voi dovete fare questa operazione:
uscire da questo stato di inanizione,
del tipo: "ma sì, sono tranquillo"
Uscire e desiderare:
ma in maniera erotica, poetica, veramente,
un'altra normalità.
Portatelo a casa e quando lo vedete,
ricordatevi che dovete fare
in questi termini.
(Applausi)